yeah so that was the thing all right
this is a patreon sponsored review which
people might have already guessed that
given that this is not really a topical
film to be talking about anymore I mean
it's more or less what kind of really
properly launched brie Larson's career
and like really set her in and now she's
a Marvel superhero so yeah let's go with
that that's tenuous why not but yes this
was a patreon sponsored review I had not
seen room before I didn't honestly know
a ton about it I had picked up like
enough bits and pieces that I I don't
think I'd ever like been told the actual
premise but I think I kind of picked up
what the initial premise was and I'd
heard it was very good and I didn't
doubt that but who I really wasn't
prepared for what I was in for I've said
in the past that endangered and or
traumatized children is difficult
viewing for me and while the I I am the
the movies four years old at this point
I am just gonna get into spoilers maybe
not quite yet but yeah I guess this is a
little bittersweet even say this much
okay but look the character of Jack
while he's a very intelligent and strong
and admirable kid he's also then we we
watch him go through situations that no
five-year-old should ever have to go
through so even coming away with the
sense that he'll
BOK seems like a stretch but that he's
gonna be as okay as someone who's been
through that stuff can be it was still
this was rough folks like for real okay
so the the opening the the the front
half was was what was really hard for me
the back half less so because it has a
very clear sort of climax point in about
the middle and then things shift and the
the tail end is more of a slow come down
from that high and I've complained in
other times that I've seen movies that I
felt very much peaked in the middle as
opposed to like the third act where you
usually stick climax this is one of the
few cases where I can think of where it
actually works and it makes sense
because for what Jack and his mother
played by brie Larson go through you
can't just have have it have their
situation change and be like oh I'm sure
everything will be fine I mean like you
kinda have to like address what what is
life now and the film takes the time to
do that and and I'll and I'll give it
props for that so the film opens with
Jack he just turned five this
long-haired little boy and his mother
Joy played by brie Larson and they live
in room that's Paul Jack knows it as
there's no windows there's a skylight
there's a door that they can't open
there's someone that Jack
knows as old Nick comes by every Sunday
brings them supplies things like that
and on those occasions Jack stays in
basically closet he calls it the
Wardrobe because otherwise he sleeps in
the bed with his mother and it doesn't
make immediately clear what it is that's
going on but like I said I kind of
picked it up like knowing a little bit
about the film ahead of time but it also
liked it it's not a twist it's not
hiding what's going on but it also it
doesn't lay it out immediately
it lets you pick up exactly what is
going on here and I think part of the
reason this was so difficult for me to
watch and also let me be clear difficult
to watch it does not equal bad there are
things that shake me and make for an
unpleasant viewing experience but that
doesn't make them bad actually more
often than not it makes them very good
at what they were trying to do more
often than not it means they really
succeeded at least for me this is the
sort of film where if I had watched this
before I had my own kid I probably it
probably still would have had some
impact guys got I mean like endangered
and traumatized kids has actually never
been easy for me to watch even when I
was a kid myself
but I know this hits me a lot harder now
and the thing is what's really great
about this is that given the situation
that it's depicting it's not
sensationalized it's not exploitative
what it actually is
is a very grounded story about the
frustrations and the fears of parenting
heightened by the specifics of this
situation but the ins and outs of Jack
and his mother and his mother's
frustrations they are elevated by the
circumstances that they're in but her
frustrations with relation to to Jack
either frustrations with him or on his
behalf
you know fears and whatnot they're
pretty Universal as far as parenting
goes needing a child to to step up for
something to you know to to lay
something that is that is very big that
is possibly more than they should be
dealing with but sometimes you have to
lay out for a child look this is the
reality of the situation or you know you
you love your kids to death but they
they can drive you nuts sometimes and
again everything is heightened by this
situation but it's never it's never
exploited it's never used in a way that
is distancing it makes everything more
intimate and it makes it read much
cleaner because honestly as far as the
core emotional resonances of the film go
and at this point like I'm gonna start
getting into more specifics about what
goes on in the second half down the line
so that's I know I said it was gonna be
a nice boys before this I'm like
properly now so if you break this thing
down to its core emotional relationship
essence it's a story of a mother with a
young boy who she raises on her own and
she worries about the impact of the
rolled on him at the same time that she
wants to share the world with him and
she worries that it's too much for him
but also knows that he needs it and she
needs to learn how to seek help for
herself which she doesn't really know
how to do she has a tendency to be
isolationist she needs to reconnect with
her own parents all of these are are
like this these themes these emotional
connections and realities could have
been told in a completely traditional
drama about just a single mother living
alone but by putting them in room and
having this be a abduction scenario it
heightens all of that and it makes it
land harder again without pushing it too
far because it very easily could have
done and the performances are really
amazing I mean from everybody because I
said it kind of peeked halfway halfway
is when they get out and they escape and
so that is very much the climax of the
story and then there was a long slow how
do we live from here out and like I said
that this film actually for the fact
that Jack is Lu was literally born
inside this shed and has never seen the
outside world you it's justified to take
literally half the runtime and just show
him trying to wrap his head around life
and his mother trying to figure out how
do things work now in terms of her life
it's
yeah I is an expertly done film and its
really strong material from a writing
standpoint from a pacing standpoint it's
kind of brilliant and especially
considering how it breaks you know
traditional climax and they do Maul if I
can be pretentious for a minute per
minute who are you getting your
pretentious all the time anyways it's
it's really it's really paced but then
it's all elevated by phenomenal
performances and also by the supporting
cast it's it is rough hmm this this was
rough viewing for me like I literally
had to pause it and like get up and walk
away for a few minutes not like extended
pairs like for literally a minute or two
like I just need to because I'm watching
when I'm watching Jack when when his
mother's trying to explain to him what
he has to do cuz she realized that she
can't get out she might be able to get
him out you know maybe if he can they
can fake him being sick enough maybe old
Nick which if you don't know is a slang
term for the devil old Nick might take
him to the hospital and then that
doesn't work in the later Jack has to
pretend to be dead
he's five years of holding he has to
pretend that he's dead in order to run
away and escape a shed that he has been
in since birth no child should have to
do that and just watching her try to
explain to him what he had to do and
seeing it in her face that she knows she
is putting too much on this child but
feeling that she has no choice anymore
it yeah it really connected in a way
that I don't think watch this movie
again kind of in the same way that like
I'm not sure I'll ever watch The Black
Mirror I've said white Christmas again
because I kind of broke me in a similar
way and along a few lines in terms of
things that hit me in sort of the way
that this film hit me this was probably
the most pleasant viewing experience
that managed to hit that
oh god this should never happen to a
child nerve that I have because other
things that have done it I mentioned the
black mirror episode or the film under
the skin things like that they do it and
they leave me shaken and deeply
unsettled this one by the hand is actual
it's it's uplifting and it's sweet but
for me and my emotional buttons it it is
hard to watch
but it is very good and I'm hesitant to
recommend and only just because I never
know like I don't use the phrase
triggered for myself and I hasn't
we use it in this case but like we'll
call it shorthand just as there's very
few things that impact me in this way
and I never know if these are things
that would impact other viewers but just
on the off-chance if if endangered and
traumatized children is tough for you
I'm not entirely sure I'd recommend it I
wouldn't warrant it off I wouldn't warn
you off from it but just realize what
you're in for
it's very good though
I was afraid because I knew it was so
well praised that I was gonna come away
going that wasn't quite all that was
cracked up to be but I think it was so
that's room add that to the list of of
crying movies have you seen it or read
the book
cuz there's the book what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it there's a bunch of stuff down
there cuz there's buttons links there's
the patreon obviously this is patreon
sponsor review I probably wouldn't have
seen this movie otherwise or at least I
wasn't planning to
plus there's other links down below you
guys been hitting the like button lately
which actually has been tangibly helping
so much appreciated
keep that up if you can all sorts of
stuff down there but you know I'm not
gonna say that you have to click it
because at the end of the day you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned